Asymmetric collapse, asymmetric collapse held with straight flight.
On the asymmetric collapse — our wings can still collapse — it's like this: when we collapse one side, that brakes the wing, so remember from making ears, anything that collapses brakes. In this case it brakes the right side quite a lot, and actually a movement to the right would result.
So the wing would like to build up dynamics to the right; we don't want that.
We want to fly straight with any disturbance, always try to fly straight. Crashing straight into something somewhere is considerably less bad than with rotation, because there we have significantly higher sink rates.
So always try to prevent the rotation.
Means for us as a reaction: if the wing collapses on one side in reality, it then usually also turns off to that side, and we want to slow that down with counter-braking.
Why only with counter-braking?
I'll explain to you right away.
In theory it's like this — you also have to tick this when the question comes up in flight practice: to stabilise the asymmetric collapse, you have to additionally put body weight onto this open side and brake a bit less with it.
But in practice it's like this: with a 50% collapse it might still work, with 60-70%, which is really more of the problem for us.
Then it no longer works.
That means you have so much load off the right riser, you can't even manage to lean it over to the left side, and it's not even helpful.
If we let the weight fall onto the collapsed side, then the riser is loaded first on the rear riser group again.
That means we help the wing to re-open much sooner.
So letting fall — you can remember this for flying too.
If we let the body weight fall, it's always good — you always load exactly the side that needs to be loaded right now.
An acro pilot does this for example.
They actually always let their body fall to the side that needs to be loaded right now.
And that's why we do it too.
Good, how can we fly the whole thing?
It's important of course that we try to fold in this 40-50% surface.
And we manage that by first of all fixing the brake on the collapse side at the press-stud.
Or magnetically.
Not like mine, that doesn't matter.
Or you simply let it go, but just don't keep it in the hand.
Because if we now pull the A-risers and have the brake in the hand, we might pull the brake a little bit along too.
And then the wing doesn't really know what to do.
Should it collapse or should it re-open?
That's why we put the brake away.
Best to fix it, then it makes the least chaos.
The other brake stays unwrapped, but all the way up at the loop in the hand.
There you can also, if you want, brace yourself a bit.
Brace against the riser so the hand doesn't fly off somewhere out into the blue.
So lightly brace against the riser.
Never grip the riser firmly, but always just brace against it.
Good, then he may come a bit forward too.
It's important that you definitely get above the line-locks of all the A-lines.
That means this ear-folding aid, you also have to take it with you.
So all the A-lines you have, take them all.
Above the line-locks.
Grip like this with the little finger up and index finger and thumb enclose the line-lock.
Like this above the line-lock.
And then you can pull.
At the start pull somewhat more slowly.
Then fix the A-lines, because otherwise they'll snap right back up on you.
So pull and where you have it, you can grip onto the main riser.
And now carefully work with the left brake.
Very gently seek heading, seek a straight heading.
And then with straight flight just keep flying like that for 3 seconds.
It's not necessarily the case that you pull the brake and then can keep it there — you might have to work a bit with it.
That's why this seeking the heading is so important.
Look at a fixed point in the terrain to the wing, look forward, ah yes, now I'm flying straight, wonderful.
Now the command comes from me, release the collapse, OK, then the right hand — that is, the collapse side — simply goes up.
The left hand continues seeking the straight heading.
Until the collapse is out and then the counter-brake can simply release up.
Under no circumstances just let everything go, because if the collapse stays in, then we turn off to the right onto the collapsed side, we don't want that.
So that's why simply stabilise the counter side until the collapse is out.
If it doesn't come out by itself, then we grab the brake, take the brake and pump once.
Bang, boom, yes, still straight flight.
Visualise, look, where is it going, OK.
Wing is still not open, 21, 22, bang, I give it another one, right?
Then it's open.
And if not, another pump.
But always space them out by two or three seconds.
And if that's the case, the wing is open, then we can go all the way up with both hands again, or with the outer hand all the way up.
Now, why work so carefully with the counter-brake?
We have a very, very short steering travel.
We have 50% surface that falls away.
That means we only have 50% surface that falls away.
Remember, wing loading rises enormously.
And with wing loading the steering point also rises.
That means we've reached the steering point much sooner.
So steering travel has become significantly shorter.
And the pressure in the wing — especially on the still open side, on the brake — that's enormously high.
That means the steering pressure has also become higher.
So you really have to fly with sensitivity, very sensitively seek the straight flight.
And of course train the whole thing a few times.
Once left, once right, so you don't focus too much on one side.
If we've now got too little surface in on the asymmetric collapse, then you can have another go.
So let go then, I'll say, let go again, go at it again.
Then you have to try to pull a bit more aggressively.
So we need 50%, that should be achievable.
We can also fly a good 60% in training or sometimes 70%, depending — when we have plenty of altitude.
But what's important is, if we really have too little and it's around 40%, then I'll tell you, pull a bit more aggressively.
So then you can go at it again, pull a bit more aggressively.
Maybe you also pull a bit deeper.
And the wing also folds away better backward from the collapsing motion.
And then again exactly the same, carefully counter-steer.
Just enough that it flies straight, and keep the straight flight until the command lets the collapse release.
And then again, as said, first release the collapse.
Then release and then the brake, when the wing is open.
Good, simply that for collapses.
Once right, once left.
Always remember, on the collapse side fix the brake beforehand.
Whoever doesn't do this and pulls the collapse down like that will see the wing won't collapse very well.
You really need the brake free, that is, not keep it in the hand at all.
Good, OK.